[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans le 7 8 dans
l'actualité de ce mardi 12 septembre la
rentrée est aussi économique le Medef
des Yvelines a convié il y a quelques
jours adhérents et élu politique pour
leur faire découvrir ses nouveaux locaux
depuis janvier l'organisation patronale
s'est installée à Montigny-le-Bretonneux
un déménagement pour s'implanter sur un
territoire riche en entreprise 17000
établissements sont basés dans
l'agglomération de 50 ans en Yvelines le
jeune céfa est décédé selon les
déclarations de son père l'adolescent
était en état de mort cérébrale après
une collision entre sa moto cross et un
véhicule de police mercredi dernier à
Élancourt l'enquête est toujours en
cours des châteaux gonflables et de
grands enfants plus de 6000 personnes
ont relevé le défi multigames samedi à
l'île de loisirs de 50 ans en Yvelines 5
km de parcours et des obstacles à
franchir le tout sous un soleil de plomb
mais dans la bonne humeur et puis de la
musique dans l'invité du 7-8 en deuxième
partie d'émission du 16 septembre au 6
octobre l'Estival fait son grand retour
dans les Yvelines cette année encore de
nombreux artistes francophones ont
répondu présent pour ses 36e édition une
Gabrielle Gontier a rencontré Kenny le
bagous responsable production du
festival
merci beaucoup voilà
c'est fait mon festif pour un nouveau
départ le Medef des Yvelines inauguré
son nouveau siège ce mercredi 6
septembre à Montigny-le-Bretonneux open
space lumineux bureau et salon pour
recevoir les adhérents près d'une
centaine d'entrepreneurs et de
personnalités politiques du département
avait fait le déplacement pour découvrir
ses locaux de 155 mètres carrés
c'est notre huitième projet de
déménagement c'est pas simple de
déménager une entreprise l'échelle
d'entreprise le savent c'est pas simple
pour nous aussi
c'est beaucoup de projets des beaux
négocier des agences immobilières à
rencontrer auparavant installer sur
Versailles le Medef des Yvelines
délocalisé ici son siège en janvier 2023
un changement encouragé par un besoin de
locaux plus spacieux nécessaire pour
recevoir les adhérents dans de bonnes
conditions un choix aussi marqué par la
volonté de s'implanter sur un territoire
d'entreprise finalement on a privilégier
50 ans qui est un centre d'affaires qui
est un cœur économique donc c'est une
ville est beaucoup de salariés avec les
fonctions qui vont avec je pense aux
transports en commun qui sont quand même
assez exceptionnel à la proximité avec
Paris parce que avec les lignes c'est 23
minutes
et puis on a de très bonnes relations
avec l'intercommunalité de 50 ans en
Yvelines mais l'idée ici c'est quand
même de pouvoir développer quelque chose
de très comment dynamique pour que les
chefs d'entreprises se connaissent au
niveau du territoire des Yvelines depuis
le sud jusqu'au nord implanté dans tous
l'Hexagone le Mouvement des Entreprises
de France est composé d'environ 70% de
TPE PME dans les Yvelines se portent
parole des entrepreneurs comptent
environ 250 adhérents
[Musique]
des collèges moins énergivores le
département investi plus de 550 millions
d'euros pour reconstruire améliorer les
performances des bâtiments ou mener des
travaux d'entretien dans les
établissements et pour faire face aux
changements climatiques la collectivité
végétalisée réaménage les cours de
récréation 3 opérations ont déjà été
réalisées durant l'été et l'année
prochaine onze nouveaux collèges seront
concernés donc à la fois on travaille le
la végétalisation l'impermanisation des
sols
du mobilier des endroits dans lequel
il y a des endroits calmes des endroits
de jeu pour que les peaux soient des
pauses ou vraiment les collégiens
passent d'un bon moment dans un
environnement pas trop chaud le
département veut également des repas
plus locaux pour ces jeunes l'objectif
est d'atteindre une part de 26% de
produits yvelinois dans l'assiette des
collégiens d'ici à la fin de l'année sur
la politique éducative les Yvelines vont
poursuivre le déploiement d'ISI ce
cartable numérique composé d'une
tablette avec clavier d'applications
après 21 établissements les élèves de 6e
et 4e et enseignant de 37 collèges vont
être équipés cette année c'est un vrai
plus ça permet vraiment de réduire la
fracture numérique vous savez que on
s'est rendu compte pendant le covid
qu'il y avait quand même beaucoup de
collégiens qui n'avaient pas accès à un
ordinateur ou un écran autre qu'un
smartphone et donc ça c'est vraiment
extrêmement important au delà des usages
pédagogiques qu'on peut avoir une
tablette c'est aussi de faire de la
vraie solidarité et ça c'est aussi l'ADN
du département parmi les autres
nouveautés le département intensifie la
présence des chargés de prévention dans
les collèges 38 établissements dans les
Yvelines ont aujourd'hui le leur ils
peuvent intervenir auprès des jeunes
notamment sur la question du harcèlement
scolaire et à l'approche des JO de Paris
2024 les sports olympiques seront à
l'honneur au travers d'ateliers
d'événements qui se dérouleront tout au
long de l'année
dans le reste de l'actualité dans les
Yvelines le jeûne CFA est décédé selon
les déclarations de son père à l'agence
de presse turques i ha l'adolescent
était en état de mort cérébrale après
une collision entre sa moto cross et un
véhicule de police mercredi dernier à
Élancourt il avait été transféré en
Turquie dans la soirée de dimanche pour
être pris en charge dans cette affaire
une information judiciaire est ouverte
pour blessure involontaire l'effet
pourrait être qualifié une fois le
certificat de décès transmis au parquet
de Versailles les mairies Yves Linois se
mobilisent pour venir en aide au Maroc
après le séisme de vendredi soir qui a
fait près de 3000 morts attrape le maire
de la commune à l’irabet a annoncé sur
Twitter débloqué 5000 euros pour le
Secours populaire le trappiste d'origine
marocaine Jamel Debbouze a lui aussi
apporté son soutien au peuple marocain
appelant aux dons dans de nombreux
médias au nord du département à
Mantes-la-Jolie une réunion est
organisée en fin de journée par le
collectif des Marocains du Mantois dans
la salle des fêtes mise à disposition
par la mairie en présence du consul et
des élus locaux il répondront aux
questions des habitants qui souhaitent
faire des dons Yaël brune Pivet victime
une nouvelle fois d'attaque antisémite
la présidente de l'Assemblée nationale a
reçu à sa permanence du Vésinet un
nouveau courrier contenant une lettre de
menace et marquée d'une étoile jaune en
mars dernier la députée yvelinoise avait
déjà été victime d'intimidation
antisémite elle a affirmé sur Twitter
porter plainte pour ne rien laisser
passer la sécurité routière un enjeu de
taille pour les entreprises alors que
l'accident routier est la première cause
de décès au travail Thalès organise
chaque année un forum pour sensibiliser
leurs salariés au risque de la route
cette année l'entreprise et
l'encourtoise signent la charte des 7
engagements initiés par la direction
départementale des territoires des
Yvelines une charte qui encourage les
employeurs à s'investir dans la
prévention routière il est important
pour la protection pour la sécurité de
nos collaborateurs et bien qu'on
progresse toujours plus avant dans les
bonnes pratiques à la fois pour soi mais
pour les autres parce que on sait que
le fait que quelqu'un ne respecte pas
les règles et peuvent pas avoir des
impacts sur autrui et donc il faut pour
être prudent pour toi et pour les autres
c'est très important pour nous et
l'entreprise de formaliser l'ensemble de
ces engagements et des mesures de
prévention sur lequel nous venons en
appui avec nos services
les journalistes attachés de presse du
monde entier réunis pour préparer les
Jeux Olympiques 2024 un briefing mondial
était organisé du 4 au 7 septembre avec
les organisateurs au programme notamment
la visite des sites dans les Yvelines
ils ont pu découvrir le drone national
de 50 ans en Yvelines le Stadium de BMX
et le château de Versailles des
enceintes sportives qui ont impressionné
les médias
[Musique]
ils ont une grande expérience pour
organiser des événements internationaux
bien sûr ce n'est pas la première fois
que Paris va organiser les Jeux
Olympiques
sera une très bonne expérience de
concourir ici
et de voir toutes sortes de matchs ici
pendant la semaine les 400 journalistes
et attachés de presse présents au plus
récolter des informations sur les
différents sites sur les accréditations
sur les transports ou la sécurité ils
ont pu poser des questions à
l'organisation
le briefing Media est très important
pour moi parce qu'il y aura beaucoup de
journalistes et de photographes qui vont
venir l'année prochaine à Paris c'est
pourquoi le briefing est très important
avec beaucoup de nouvelles informations
qui nous arrivent après le château de
Versailles il a tourné c'est terminé par
la visite des sites olympiques parisiens
le briefing s'est ensuite clôturé par un
discours de la ministre des Sports
Amélie ou des à Casteras les médias se
retrouveront désormais l'année prochaine
pour les JO il devrait être plus de 4000
journalistes et 1500 photographes
acritée
[Musique]
j'ai vu un saut de très haut là et on
tombe dans une piscine voilà j'aime bien
faire ça
un soleil de plomb et la chaleur
n'auront pas eu raison de leur
motivation
les voilà partis pour un parcours à
travers l'île de loisirs de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines les bullsky
games avaient posé leur structure
gonflable 9 septembre dernier
le premier là
échelle corde glissade passer l'aspect
récréatif les difficultés techniques se
sont enchaînées 5 km et 12 obstacles à
passer avec le petit bonheur
c'est très bien ça fait du bien cette
journée
S
c'est super et à tous ceux qui hésitent
faites-le dès que ça vient dans votre
région faites-le c'est génial
6300 grands enfants ont relevé le
challenge en venant de partout en France
et de plus loin c'est un devoir pour
nous on voulait s'amuser on est une asso
du personnel d'un établissement public
et on a envie de créer de la cohésion
entre
collègues à cette manifestation pas de
vainqueur juste du fun les structures
ont été dégonflés direction la ville de
Rouen
le retour au calme demain après la
journée orageuse de ce mardi prévoyez
des éclaircies mercredi matin dans le
département il fera 17 degrés dans le
secteur de Mantes-la-Jolie 16 degrés sur
le reste du territoire yvelinois demain
après-midi le temps ne devrait que très
peu évoluer côté température comptait 22
degrés dans la moitié nord des Yvelines
21 degrés à Rambouillet et demain nous
fêterons les aimer tout de suite
l'invité du 7 8 avec Gabriel Montier
[Musique]
le 16 septembre la 36e édition de
l'Estival et de retour à Poissy cette
année le festival musical revient avec
de nombreux artistes Kenny le bagouce
bonjour vous êtes le responsable
production de l'Estival merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation alors j'imagine
que vous attendez à le lancement de
cette 36e édition avec impatience
l'heure elle est encore aux préparatifs
aujourd'hui l'heure et Léo préparatifs
puisque le festival commence dans
quelques jours avec le premier concert
aura lieu dans cette salle au théâtre de
Poissy l'occasion des Journées
européennes du patrimoine on est dans la
dernière ligne droite et justement
qu'est-ce que vous avez prévu pour ce
premier week-end avec les journées du
patrimoine et ben en fait on va proposer
un spectacle très belles original par sa
forme et son contenu qui est le baba de
la chanson c'est un spectacle mené par
Jules un artiste du 95 donc pas très
loin d'ici qui a invité plein d'autres
gens mais les semelles wali et ils vont
revisiter en fait le la chanson
française sous forme d'un c'est un genre
d'abécédaire ils vont s'attaquer au lac
CDEF donc ça va être de Cabrel à Céline
Dion en passant par Calogero à leur
façon c'est très drôle c'est un peu
déjanté et ça colle bien avec cette idée
de patrimoine
et de la chanson et des Journées
européennes du patrimoine et justement
la chanson elle est au cœur de l'Estival
depuis 1988 l'Estival c'est imposé dans
les Yvelines comme un festival de
référence en quoi ce festival il est
important aujourd'hui encore dans les
Yvelines festival il est important parce
que il a une ligne éditoriale assez
singulière en Île-de-France qui est la
défense de la chanson francophone et pas
forcément française mais francophone
dans sous toutes ses formes et on
accueille des artistes
aux origines venues d'Afrique du Canada
de Suisse Belgique
la Franc la chanson française c'est pas
que la France c'est aussi la
francophonie dans toute sa diversité de
style musical aussi on a des fois
tendance à penser que la chanson c'est
un piano voit une guitare voix et ben
pas forcément ça peut prendre plein de
formes on accueille cette année Suzanne
avec sa chance c'est de la chanson
électro ou de sagaçant c'est des
nouvelles formes de chansons à texte
avec des textes très beaux très forts
mais l'enrobage musical autour et
moderne et c'est aussi ça la chanson
actuelle et justement alors vous avez
commencé à nous parler de certains des
artistes la grande force de l'Estival
c'est également d'avoir des grandes voix
mais aussi des artistes émergents ce que
vous pouvez nous donner quelques noms de
ces artistes qu'on connaît déjà et qu'on
va découvrir oui l'idée de l'Estival a
toujours été de programmer des premières
parties ce qui permet au public de
découvrir de jeunes talents ou de
nouveaux talons alors en effet cette
année on va voir la chance d'accueillir
Camille Lellouche ici même
Chimène Badi
mais aussi à haute sagaçant au sac à HR
qui est quand même l'étoile montante de
la chanson depuis quelques mois on a une
très belle soirée avec Suzanne au forum
Armand Peugeot à Poissy autour de la
chanson électro on a on a aussi les
spectacle qui nous tient vraiment à cœur
qui sont les vitrines découvertes c'est
un plateau de 6 artistes qui vont
proposer et montrer leur univers leur
talent un panel de directeurs festival
de directeur de salles c'est aussi un de
ça un des engagements de l'Estival sur
la chanson et justement Kenny je vous
propose qu'on écoute quelques extraits
de ces artistes qu'on découvrira à
l'Estival
[Musique]
j'ai ouvert tous mes chakras les signes
je les reçois je fais là pour aller dans
il fait toujours beau au-dessus des
nuages mais moi si j'étais un oiseau
j'irai danser sous l'orage cette année
c'est une saison particulière c'est la
première saison sans Mark Pfeiffer qui
est à l'origine de l'Estival pourquoi
c'était important de continuer et de lui
rendre hommage également en effet
disparu en tout début d'année il a créé
ce festival il y a 36 ans avec une bande
d'amis
on est tous persuadés que c'est ce qu'il
aurait voulu que l'Estival continue
malgré son absence tout en gardant les
fondamentaux qu'il a toujours voulu
défendre la défense des artistes du
spectacle et donc c'était important de
continuer ce qu'il avait ce qu'il a
amorcé il y a presque 40 ans
et surtout le concert d'ouverture donc
avec le Baaba de la chanson c'est un
concert mené par Jules qui a un artiste
que marque aimait beaucoup connaissait
bien ça fait des années qu'on le
soutient et qu'on suit son travail il a
été comme nous tous très affecté par sa
disparition donc c'est aussi une manière
de rejoindre les ponts vous nous parlez
des grandes valeurs de ce festival parmi
les grandes valeurs il y a la valeur
associative cette année est-ce que vous
pouvez nous parler un petit peu de la
grande cause que vous allez soutenir
donc cette année on soutient le gemme
des lumières qui est une association
d'accueil de jeunes adultes
ça leur permet de trouver un lien social
de retrouver surtout un lien social un
lien
affectif pour certains mais aussi des
valeurs de sortie d'entraide pour des
gens qui sont renfermés qui se sont
renfermés dans la dépression ou dans
d'autres problèmes de ce type là comme
tous les ans tous les bénéfices du bar
des produits de vente dérivés iront
intégralement à cette association alors
Kenny le bagous nous sommes au théâtre
de Poissy qui va accueillir de nombreux
artistes quels sont les autres villes
dans lesquelles vont s'implanter le
l'Estival cette année donc cette année
nous aurons des spectacles dans cinq
villes des Yvelines où ils montaient son
le PEC évidemment Poissy et HR par
exemple à HR on va proposer donc les
vitrines découvertes à haute-sagaçant
mais aussi à l'occasion de la fête du
céleri un spectacle puisque c'est même
pas un concert c'est un specte c'est un
vrai spectacle de rue gratuit ouvert à
tous à l'occasion de la fête du céleri
avec les frères jacquard c'est un
spectacle musical humoristique c'est
très drôle c'est pour toute la famille
le 30 septembre et justement c'est une
nouveauté de l'Estival de s'implanter un
petit peu plus dans les événements
locaux pourquoi vous avez décidé de
changer un petit peu la forme d'évoluer
aussi oui c'est aussi une façon de
trouver du lien avec les différentes
communes les différents publics donc on
s'est inséré comme vous dites à la fête
du céleri à Achères mais aussi à la fête
de l'air à Montesson qui sont des
événements attendus par les populations
et nous on vient apporter notre
expertise sur la musique ou sur la
programmation d'artistes ça nous permet
ça permet aussi à ces événements de
grandir un peu mais aussi de faire
découvrir de la musique gratuitement
puisque tous ces événements sont
gratuits d'autres manières que d'être
dans un théâtre ou dans une salle de
spectacle l'autre force de l'Estival
c'est de proposer des artistes très
différents il y en aura pour tous les
goûts cette année
j'espère on a essayé de faire une
programmation la plus éclectique
possible ça va de la grande chanson
française avec Chimène Badi qui chante
Piaf Louis Chedid Yvan Cassard qui sont
des artistes qu'on présente plus depuis
bien longtemps mais aussi la jeune
génération avec Suzanne doutes saga 100
ou bien Camille Lellouche mais aussi du
slam au théâtre blanche de casting une
soirée folle que au club Peggy mené par
Étienne Fletcher ou à Houilles une
soirée plus chanson rock avec cancre
sueur c'est aussi des artistes de la
nouvelle génération pour ceux qui n'ont
pas encore pris leur place pourquoi il
faut venir à l'Estival cette année pour
passer un bon moment écoutez de la belle
musique et bien ce sera le mot de la fin
merci Kenny le bacous d'avoir répondu à
nos questions alors l'Estival c'est du
16 septembre au 7 octobre on vous
souhaite un bon festival et on vous
souhaite une très belle soirée sur TV 78
[Musique]